we are concerned about the energy  situation in europe because it  demonstrates the vulnerability of being  too dependent on one supplier of  natural gas  there could be an interruption of gas  supplies however the russian government  should weigh carefully whether they  really want that while it's possible to  put europe under pressure europe would  eventually turn to liquid gas from other  countries  [Music]  qatar is in a very good position to  supply lng uh to and to do it  strategically you know it's not just for  sale now you can see in europe there's  an effort to  use the production and distribution of  qatari gas in a way that strengthens the  global coalition to say to russia no you  can't invade ukraine that's not no  that's not okay  it's a very important role for qatar to  play  [Music]  [Music]  you